holy crap everybody they screen some new
Star Wars footage from a last Jedi so
I'm going to explain what's going on
because this is so awesome I'm giving
away rogue one blu-rays all you have to
do to enter that is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video if you
don't know what happened Disney had a
special shareholders meeting that it
does every year where they reveal
everything about what's going on with
the theme parks like they're building
Star Wars land they talk about all their
big franchise movies because Disney
earns billions and billions of dollars
for their shareholders so they screen
footage for of all the upcoming projects
so one that people will lose their minds
over how cool it's going to look into
because the business people want to earn
a lot of money so there's that side to
it too but it's really just cool because
you get a look at what's going to be
coming down the pipe and of course
because it's a saga year they screen
Star Wars the last Jedi footage they
screen footage from Thor Ragnarok now
this is a Star Wars video I'll do a
separate video for a Thor stuff because
there was a whole bunch of other stuff
to drop today but here's a breakdown of
what was in that Star Wars footage and
it's about what you'd expect it wasn't
like an official trailer but it was a
lot of footage that will probably wind
up in the trailer when they post that at
Star Wars Celebration in April so I'll
remind everybody about that at the end
of the video because that's when they're
probably make all this footage available
but here's the deal so it started off
kind of funny it was a bit
tongue-in-cheek because they're still
editing the film they're still working
on special effects so there's not as
much footage to show off as you would
think but they pick up in that final
scene from Star Wars The Force awakens
where Rey is handing Luke the lightsaber
Rey asks them who are you as he picks up
his father's lightsaber then they jump
the footage of Chewbacca Leia with the
resistance
then and then a big montage of a bunch
of a different location so they're going
to be visiting mountains oceans forests
deserts basically every type of Star
Wars location you could probably think
of the planet that they're on here ock 2
is actually relatively aquatic at least
this area that they're in so that might
be the ocean that they're referring to
there's a lot of Rey training that's
going to be happening there so in the
way that the force awakens sort of
jumped around to the different
characters storylines and we got to see
different types of terrain obviously the
same thing is going to be happening so
not all the characters will be traveling
together for the entire film Finn has
his own resistance that that's going on
there are a lot of rumors about how he's
going to be working is an infiltrator
for the first order but one of the last
big clips that they showed off was this
x-wing wobbling midair under attack from
a giant ship looking like his really
Wounded Bird so really this is just a
highlight reel it doesn't tell you too
much about what the story is going to be
they're going to save a lot of that for
Star Wars Celebration the big panel that
they'll do for the movie but the big
takeaway from this is raised dialogue
who are you asking Luke Skywalker it's a
bit of a general term they're using it
an ambiguous way like who are you
are you a Jedi like it what is Rey going
to become what are you going to become
that's actually a line from rogue one
what will you become if they break you
is used in a very different way but the
context is the same like people just
making the choice to become something
else like deciding who they're going to
be there was also talk about Pope in the
resistance characters trying to sabotage
a new first order weapon now I know
everybody jokes about the idea that
making another Death Star in star wars
the force awakens so that's not going to
be happening in the last Jedi but that
doesn't mean that they're going to stop
building weapons of mass destruction
so mercifully no more death stars but
there still will be really crazy weapons
that they're building and because the
movie is picking up in the exact moment
after the force awakens there's no way
they'd have time to build another star
killer base that sounds like it took
them 20 plus years to build and there's
a little bit of Empires and the book
that was released that explains a little
bit about their time in the Unknown
Regions about how the remnants of the
Empire sort of left after the battle of
jakku that was like the last big battle
between the rebellion in the empire went
into the unknown region and sort of
disappeared from view for many years
until they resurfaced inserted building
support in the Senate they found a lot
of sympathizers in ways to fund the
creation of the Starkiller base but that
took many many years to complete in the
Unknown Regions so that's how they can
build something that big it can show up
during the force awakens and the other
characters don't really know about it
although Leia probably had suspicions
she sounds like she was one of the few
people that knew about the threat of the
first order and wanted to do something
about it whereas the other members of
the New Republic didn't
very seriously which allowed them the
time to complete this weapon literally
build a weapon into a planet in for
those of you that had questions about
the logic of that they could actually
move that around because it basically
drains a star to power itself they
explained after the movie came out
obviously it was blown up so the weapon
doesn't matter but it was able to move
itself with hyperdrive to other systems
so that it could use another Sun to
power another blast but aside from
swooping in to fill the vacuum left by
the destruction of the New Republic
during Force awakens we don't know too
much about what the first orders next
plans are because they're still trying
to find Luke Skywalker so that's a very
kylo Ren centric mission but the rest of
the first order is probably rushing in
to strengthen their stranglehold on the
galaxy like it's one thing to swoop in
with a bunch of ships and take over a
planet but there are many many planets
in the New Republic so a more effective
route would be for them to take over
what's the left of the New Republic and
then form a new government under the
first order in that way they won't have
to conquer all those planets one by one
they'll just fall in line the way they
did during the original trilogy so it
sounds like based on the description of
the footage they screened off what's
going to happen is is they're going to
split a lot of the first order story
with thin impose characters the
resistance characters like general Leia
in the more Force centric stuff with
kylo Ren Snoke Luke in Rey's character
so usually what happens is by the climax
of any film all those storylines sort of
converge but they start off in very
different places so it sounds like Rey
is going to be on octave for a while
while Finn and Poe decide what their
next move is going to be try to
infiltrate the first-order and find out
what their plans are then the thing I
know we're all really getting hyped
about is Luke leaving the planet
traveling with her obi-wan Kenobi style
and then just going on some crazy
adventure that eventually causes them to
meet up with the other characters but
the other really cool Luke Skywalker's
stuff JJ Abrams has seen most of the
film obviously because he's still a big
producer on the song even though he's
not directing it he didn't write it is
that he said Mark Hamill deserves an
Oscar for his performance in the last
Jedi
now obviously the Oscars have a history
of hating genre films so I don't think
any of us actually expect Star Wars to
win any
oscar's maybe some technical oscars
those are a little bit easier hugh
jackman - Loganville might break that
street because a lot of people are
talking about Patrick Stewart for Best
Supporting Actor Oscar just because he's
doing this crazy King Lear impression
but let me know in the comments what do
you think it's going to take for Star
Wars somebody from the Star Wars
universe to win Best Actor Best
Supporting Actor like it I mean it's
going to take the performance of a
lifetime but the powers that be are
calling the last Jedi the perfect
chapter in the iconic Skywalker family
drama
so that heavily relies on Skywalker
family so even though there's a lot of
first-order stuff going on in that ties
in with Leia's character this is all
about the force in the lineage of Anakin
Skywalker so I know it's kind of crazy
now because so many other Marvel movies
are dropping information there's all
this store stuff to drop today there's
Wonder Woman stuff happening we have
Justice League there's all the infinity
war stuff I still feel like the last
Jedi will probably be the biggest movie
this year just because even though Star
Wars has been a little bit quieter
lately because it hasn't been around for
as long they just came back with the
force awakens it will roar into December
and even though the last Jedi probably
won't gross quite as much globally as
the force awakens did it will still
learn way more money than any of the
other films this year so let me know in
the comments here's a big question do
you actually think that the last Jedi
will earn more money at the box office
then the force awakens did I feel like
the only reason it won't is because they
spent so much money marketing the force
awakens and it was the first new Star
Wars film in like 10 years
so everybody that would normally not be
going to the movie theater just came out
to see what was going to happen so once
you get a few more Star Wars movies
under your belt people are like okay you
know another Star Wars all wait for it
to come out on DVD I'll wait for it to
come out on Netflix so even though
everyone will watch the movie it's just
not as many people will go to see the
sequels as went to see that first
brand-new Star Wars movie so at the end
of the day it's not that big a deal
because it's still going to earn
billions and billions of dollars between
the theatrical release the toys that
they sell in everything else
so remember when Disney bought Star Wars
they bought the rights to everything
including the merchandising so like for
every twenty dollar movie ticket that
people buy
they spend like $40.00 on toys so they
aren't way more money on that side of
the business but I'm just so happy with
all the stuff that's dropping today
there's so much good news so I'll try to
get through all the videos as much as
possible there's new thor ragnarok
there's some new flash footage that I'm
going to post later tonight so soar
might not post till Thursday morning and
there's a couple other TV episodes that
I'm going to try and post videos for so
I'll update the video schedule as I go
along and because I'm in Star Wars
Friday last week I'm going to try and
think of something cool to do for this
weekend but let me know what you want me
to do for that next Star Wars video
while you wait for that you can click
here to learn more about what's going on
with Rey and last Jedi and you can click
here to learn all about a brand new game
of Thrones character thank you so much
for watching let's not buy off you guys
in the next video
vinicky me anything
[Music]